Lolade Nwanze and her team in The Guardian
newsroom check the top social media topics
every morning.
On Twitter, an advisor to the Nigerian president
alleges that an opposition party is offering
food and money in exchange for votes.
The news speads quickly - so the Guardian
team decides to investigate.
“We researched the image and found out it
was a lie.
The photograph dated as far back as 2017.
It was a photograph from an outreach done
by a charity foundation in Lagos.
So it wasn’t what she said it was.”
Shortly after the Guardian publishes its findings,
the politician's Tweets are deleted.
The team here say they see fake stories like
this every day.
“If it is text, it is a lot easier.
You just need to call up a few people, whoever
is making this claim.
If it is photographs it is also somewhat easy.
The technology is quite simple to handle,
you can reverse search and so on.
But when it is video, it becomes a little
bit more complicated.
Once video gets on social media, usually on
Twitter, you have the meta data stripped off.
And sometimes this is what you need actually
to track a video.
So video makes it a bit complicated, and audio
files as well.”
To check these kinds of stories, the Guardian
has teamed up with some 20 other media outlets.
They've formed a collective called 'Cross
Check Nigeria' to support each other in the
research process.
A story only goes online when four of the
different media organisations have looked
at it.
Dayo Aiyetan is one of the coordinators.
Around 50 journalists are involved in the
project.
“Everywhere in the world, even in the most
technologically advanced US, politicians would
always use any means to gain advantage.
If it is by weaponizing information – they
will do that.
But the important thing is, when they know
once they try it, there will be mechanisms
– use of of technology – that can also
out them.
And perhaps that will reduce the incidents
of politicians weaponizing information for
their advantage or to do damage.”
Aiyetan says the number of fake stories has
increased in the run up to the elections.
Nigeria is the most populous country in Africa
and it's divided along ethnic lines - which
often leads to conflict.
According to Nigerian police, there have already
been cases of fase reports causing violence.
So it is not only newspapers who are reacting
to increasing levels of fake news – even
Facebook is acknowledging the issue: 10 tips
to spot false news– A tech giant advertising
in a traditional newspaper.
Lolade Nwanze thinks there has been a change
in the news business in recently.
Rather than publishers competing against each
other to be the first to break a story, they
are now working together to separate fact
from fiction.
In times of falling newspaper circulation,
she says, this could be an opportunity for
Nigerian media companies.